I'm right you know what time it is
it's movie retrospective time yeah I am
super excited about this a good one oh
my goodness okay
this is how this [ __ ] happened yeah so
this movie came out in 2007 yeah
now you had seen it I saw it for you yes
didn't know anything about you didn't
know anything about it you had seen it
before now this was even before we moved
in together yeah this was just when we
going out yeah this was at your old
apartment right so I was over at your
apartment yeah one day and you're like
you have to see this movies yeah
craziest [ __ ] you I was lying I started
on this on that on this movie and it was
called big man Japan yeah I didn't know
anything about it I didn't know the
premise I didn't see anything at all but
I think it was Netflix and somehow it
just kind of rolled into it right okay
yeah I'll watch this one and I start
watching it and it just seems like this
serious kind of documentary about this
guy who's kind of down and out and it's
just real serious you know and he's
talking about his wife and his wife
threw a brick through the window and I'm
was like this can't be you know I mean a
reality type program yeah and then one
thing just kind of built into another
and it was just I couldn't believe what
I was seeing you guys I haven't seen big
man Japan don't watch this don't wanna
ruin it turn this [ __ ] off now go watch
it go watch it back this is one where
the less you know the more effective it
is I had no idea what kind of movie this
was I didn't know the genre or anything
he just seemed like you know like a
documentary about a guy who was in Japan
who was kind of down on his luck and one
thing led to another and you find out
this guy's got a different identity just
turn it off right now yeah go why cuz
we're gonna spoil it you're gonna spoil
it but yeah and actually it's on shutter
shutter dude that's what I was gonna say
like I was gonna say skip ahead because
he had seen it he showed it he's like
you have to see this is a crazy [ __ ]
ever yeah I tell everything and you
didn't tell me anything
you said you just have to watch just
watch it yeah so I sat there in his
apartment I watched it and I'm like holy
[ __ ] that was like the funniest [ __ ]
thing I've ever seen
and then fast-forward to like a week or
two ago I'm I you know come up on
shutter like I check it every day or a
couple days they were around to present
and I up there like on their new
releases and I literally said out loud
no [ __ ] way I was like this has been
on the list for like ages and I wanted
to get around to doing this because this
is like the crazy so movie and I feel
like a lot of people haven't seen it
maybe yeah so we're gonna go ahead and
we're gonna do this one now so if you
guys haven't seen it go ahead and turn
it off and you got but yeah this movie
as I said is came out in 2007 yes how
are there spoilers yeah okay so we're
warning you this yes
okay so just turn back now turn back now
um came out in 2007 is called big man
Japan it was written directed and stars
quite famous Japanese comedian Satoshi
Matsumoto yeah and I didn't know the guy
was comedian yeah I'm watching it and I
didn't either when I first was you know
we don't know this guy's you know before
all we know this is like the Japanese
Robin Williams I was taking seriously
you know and then it just out of the
blue got so bizarre and just bust up you
just you can't handle it so yeah because
I love okay here's the thing like I
haven't seen a lot of I've seen a lot of
Japanese horror films like monster
movies stuff like that
I haven't seen a lot of Japanese
comedies but the ones that I have seen
have tended to be tend more toward the
zany end of things right so is anything
funny so I think the reason this one
works is because a lot of it is very
low-key you know what I mean wrong it's
very dry humor and the guy just plays
his role totally straight yes and then
just some batshit crazy stuff just comes
out of nowhere with yeah hardly any
presentation or being able to it what
this movie is is you find out this guy
who's down
now he doesn't he's not getting regular
work like he used to give and you find
out that what he is is that he is a
sentai character and if you know
anything about Japanese movies sentai is
kind of like you know the giant monsters
like Godzilla yeah
Rodan that he can get big when he needs
to and he gets big I'll just crack it up
just by going down to the local power
plant and they hook up some [ __ ] to his
nipples and they [ __ ] to shock him and
he grows huge just in a few seconds and
then he can go out and fight a monster
and over a period of a few days he gets
depressed and he gets smaller and small
goes back to normal size
yeah and they introduced this concept
you just straight his [ __ ] just that
this is real big man Japan and he
doesn't have the work he used to have
because it's not quite popular and that
as it used to be there's not as many
monsters they don't show up regularly in
Japan anymore and the public's kind of
turned against him because he's more
trouble than he's worth they break a lot
of buildings and [ __ ] yeah he steps like
he's bad for the environment yeah bad
example for children because it's
violent it's hilarious yeah so this
guy's character's name is Massaro Dai
Sato and at the beginning of this movie
it's but it's a mockumentary is what it
is so that you never see the person
behind the camera but it's just it's
obviously like someone behind the camera
making a documentary about this guys and
get big yeah now but they don't tell it
like at the beginning he's just kind of
like slumming around in his bachelor pad
which is all cluttered [ __ ] like yeah
and they're asking him separated from
his wife yeah they're asking him kind of
mundane questions like about his life
and stuff like that and as he starts
getting into like what his job is and
stuff because they don't tell you that
for quite a while like a little bit yeah
and it's like so it's almost like
because the first time I watched it I
was like are we watching like a
documentary about a crazy person is that
what this is [ __ ] because that's what it
seems like it seems like she's very real
yeah is he cause he looks he dresses
kind of
hobo and he's always kind of like you
know shuffling around and he seems like
really depressed and bummed out and he
lives by himself his wife and kid are
gone and all this other stuff and he
just seems very sad and lahic
kind of I didn't realize if I didn't
rise this was a mockumentary until he's
in the middle of his bit of he's out in
the park talking about you know how I
was kind of estranged from his wife and
he doesn't get this he doesn't get to
see his his daughter very oh yeah he
said once a month but it was more like
once every five months or yeah it was
kind of an unreliable there yeah he kind
of lied about and then he gets a call on
his cell phone he goes dude I got work
and it's like really you got a work is
yeah and he goes don't film me man I'm
telling you no he's trying to hide what
he does and he goes I got to go man
gotta go he said I gotta go bake gotta
go bake in what any jumps on him jumps
on his motorcycle it's like a little
moped yeah and he starts heading up this
mountain there's always silly signs and
I'm going what the hell is this and the
guy the guide tried to do the
documentaries follow him behind him in
the car
and he gets to a power station and the
security won't let him through and he
good and he's telling us look man I
gotta do this make a long story short he
grows [ __ ] huge size of Godzilla
that's what I realized that this this
movie was full of [ __ ] but it was
[ __ ] hilarious
and the monsters that he's fighting are
just the most looser monsters ever and
they're just the most ludicrous that you
can imagine and and and they're kind of
trying to take it seriously and then
they talk after he gets small again you
know he asks about the ratings and his
ratings are underneath the shopping
channel like it's not popular yeah they
show like the radio like the tea his
managers stealin most of his money he's
not really and he's living on welfare a
lot of it gets or something like
somebody's like the Ministry of Defence
but yeah that's what Jamie's government
still paying him yeah they have a
Ministry of monster prevention yeah and
he's saying that because he actually
comes from a long line which is a gig
they had Japan yeah dudes that fought
monsters now yeah his grandfather the
fourth the fourth he just calls him the
fourth is still alive
and he was kind of like the super big
popular one so like sometimes in the
movie they show like this archival
footage yeah family black and white in
Japan black and white really world war
two yeah like this like this other like
big man he's walking the street never
was cheering and loquacious like the
door open right like in his bag and [ __ ]
like that and it's like but at this
stage I guess like I said the you know
the public is kind of turned against him
nobody really watches because all of his
monster fights are televised for
whatever reason he has an agent and
stuff but no one really gives a crap
anymore because I guess out of style
yeah and it's like you know the monsters
are kind of lame and they show up and
they don't show up very often and they
stuck him like on a two o'clock in the
morning and [ __ ] like that one he is
he's like you know his grandfather used
to have like the primetime slot
everything like that but I want to I
want to say to like how [ __ ] awesome
the monsters that he fights are like
this it's hard to describe if you
haven't seen them but like the first one
he fights and before each little monster
fight they'll have like a little it
looks like old paper and it'll be like
it'll show you like a like it's an old
like book and it'll show you like the
name of the monster and a little sketch
of it and what it does and it's like
these are the attributes of the whatever
monster might be where they showed you
and they give us the stats fragments
like that one of them was just a giant
head with one single leg with one leg
and it was like an idiotic child and it
just jumped around that was the leaping
month yeah another one would just look
like a like a chick without any you know
like a look like a baby chick like a
plucked yeah chicken right with a with
no head with like a worm coming out
where his butt is with an eye on it and
it was thrown yeah it was like coming
out of his belly and it had like this
big long like thing with a big huge
eyeball and imitating through like that
was his weapon I'm just like a snake
monster just yeah the fur actually the
first one he fought was like um I think
it was called the strangling monster and
it kind of looked like okay like its
body looked like sort of like the
Michelin Man except skinny like it was
kind of like looked like it was
wrapped in bandages like oh yeah yeah I
remember and then but it's two arms and
like a rubber band we're connected like
a rubber band and his thing was he would
put his arms around a building and he
would pull a building up out of the
ground and then he would had a
ovipositor that came out of his butthole
yeah and he would stick it like in the
ground
nobody had a comb-over
oh no but yeah cool what oh man one of
them was just a giant baby baby with cat
ears on it like a cat yeah he killed
that that was accidental yeah you killed
that one and everybody was accusing him
of murdering a baby and murdering babies
and he was hiding out you know it it's
just it's awesome Flik it's a bit like I
said it real funny I think the funniest
thing about it is just like the
juxtaposition of this apparently very
serious like documentary footage of this
poor like you know trodden down man
yeah you think that is about and then
these like inner inner cutscenes of like
him fighting these moths bottom is a
swim waiting on Korean monster when he
gets big yeah um
his hair goes like he has like big yeah
yuppie hair and he just has like old
stick and he doesn't have any shirt on
he just has a little purple underwear
Yakuza tattoos
yeah and he has all these tattoos and
some of the tattoos are like
advertisements because that's how they
make like sponsor money like that's his
his agent said all that and there's like
there's like a couple scenes or he's
like arguing with his agent like in the
diner about like how he doesn't want any
tattoos on his hips and yeah you know my
hips are like secret property and stuff
but it's just the there's just like
little funny [ __ ] like that like the one
of the very first scenes in the movie
which kind of like you know where he's
on the bus and he's got like an umbrella
and the dot you know one of those little
fold up umbrellas it's like you know
this big and the documentary guy asked
him he's like I didn't think it was
gonna rain today so I go I always carry
one I really like these kind of
umbrellas they get big when you need
them too
yeah right he always like stuff that
gets bigger he like stuff that gets big
when you need it to because he always
has he also has this like seaweed let's
strike dry seaweed it gets
and when you put it in water it like
expands yeah and he was talking about
that - he's like yeah I really like this
because he gets big when he big boy
it's a big box yeah just little [ __ ]
like that but it's done like really
really subtle yeah another thing that I
thought was really funny was um like I
said his successor his grandfather the
fourth is still alive and he's in like a
nursing home yeah he's got dementia and
he's got dementia and at one stage like
late in the movie like he gets a phone
call from the nursing home and there's
no preamble and all the guy that nursing
home just says your grandpa got big show
show him the Newsies he's going up to
like smokestacks on smokestacks for
factories yeah and then he salutes the
son and that would that end up being the
first like like the front page news that
he's saluting the Sun and that he's
crazy it's just funny yeah if you ever
wanted to see like a gigantic old man
yeah in underwear
you're be proportioned when you see him
yeah like they're really weird look at
them horses narrow shoulders and little
arms and big legs and big tall head long
necks on them big tall hair looks like
something off a dam Eraserhead yeah it
real good story and another thing they
don't look heroic at all another thing
that's funny too is whatever big man
Japan gets called out on a job because
he says like to the documentary guy he's
like most time I'm just sitting around
because it's like monsters don't come
around you know as I bid he's like I but
I can't take a vacation because you
never know like one might come around
tomorrow or later today and I need to be
on call I'm always on call so whenever
he gets a call there's only like three
or four power plants left in Japan so he
always definitely take a bus or like
whatever to get there and then they hook
up his nipples and all well first they
have to do like this super secret like
ritual they got like the priests of the
Shinto priests in there or whatever and
he's got a call in the spirit of some
goddess and yeah as invested its vested
yeah he's like didn't they ask who's
this is it accidently necessary he's
like nah you find out all this [ __ ]
does is like not necessary it's just
pretty it's just they just do it like
all happened because yeah and then he
goes out like before when they go to
make him big he goes out and this is the
funniest thing to you and I read a
review of this by Roger Ebert or whoever
writes his website now cuz I don't
remember Frederator was still alive in
2009 who actually loved this movie and
um he was like this this is the movie
that answered a lot of questions I had
about superheroes like especially like
Hulk ones or ones that get big he's like
you know how did they get into their
clothes like how did the clothes grew it
was like this answers that question
because they have his big huge purple
underwear
yes it's held up already and he gets in
there and he's normal size and he gets
in and just stands in the crotch and
fills it up yeah but there's just like
there's all kinds of there's like like I
said there's the stink monster you know
about his bad relationship with his dad
cuz his dad traumatized him when he was
a kid yeah he was getting fat as a
little boy and his dad said it's time to
give you some juice you know I mean yeah
and they've hooked up the dam cuz his
dad could get big look at his grandad
yeah they hooked up his nipples and gave
him too much voltage and he just blew
his titties out like volcano red-hot
he's laying on the ground you know
knocked out and and the fourth his
granddad came in and you know that's my
remember he's like smacked his dad yeah
I remember his dad ended up dying yeah
he was trying to give himself too much
news he was trying to get bigger getting
bigger and bigger yeah and and like he
was you know during the interviews he
was talking about his how his dad and
his granddad where they were adversely
affected by taking too much away because
they were literally trying to get head
and shoulders above the rest of the
competition because there were more guys
that could get big too at the same time
like thirty of them and the interview
was like what is more electricity make
you bigger and he went no ya know so
there's some where it ever so weird
mysterious [ __ ] if he if more
electricity didn't make you bigger why
did they give themselves more
electricity and how did they get head
and shoulders above the rest
maybe they didn't maybe they
they just thought they did I don't know
I think it was an analogy with steroids
or something probably something like
that yeah I just thought the for the
first time I saw it I have to tell you
this when he was talking about the
umbrella and he's like he liked it
because it got big when you need it too
big when you need one of the sometimes
one of the funnest movies I've ever seen
not knowing anything about it it made it
made it look really funny cuz I did what
I was watching and then it gets it gets
progressively more and more bizarre
until it turns into the modern sentai
words Ultraman yeah but it's a it's a
whole family of American version of
Ultraman show up and defeat the North
Korean monster and the Japanese big man
Japan made no difference yeah they
showed that that he made no difference
in the destruction of this monster which
which calls back to the towards the
beginning of the movie when they said
don't you like to go on vacation maybe
to American he's like no i yeah he
didn't he didn't like America he said
when he was a kid his father and his
grandfather kind of they fed him some
ideas which they were you know they were
inferred that he was a Japanese
nationalist
okay she had like never been anywhere
near been anywhere he was an ultra
nationalist you know he was into the
empire but I think like I said I think
the thing that makes this so funny is
just because I mean you have to have
like a particularly a particular sense
of humor but it's just because it's
taken so seriously and it's just so
serious and you just think it's like
this documentary about this loser
Japanese dude who is crazy and thinks
he's a superhero but then he actually is
but then it's just funny the way
everyone like reacts to it because it
feels like you know in a lot of you know
it's definitely satirical in a lot of
these kind of movies about giant
monsters and giant people and stuff like
that you know everyone's like oh you
know what I mean but now everybody's
just like meh yeah it's like no one's
watching it it's like you know his whole
house is like covered was like graffiti
and people throwing rocks through his
windows
like that because it's like no one's
having it anymore and it's just so I
think that was what I liked the most
about it is that the the total straight
[ __ ] of like the documentary stuff with
just the completely ludicrous you know
there's a scene in this with like the
stink monster and he's like and then
there's another stink monster and then
they're arguing about over whether he
should have sex with this other stink
monster I said it was T was too young
and he's like yeah he's too young and
everything like that but then apparently
it did go too and there's just there's
so many bubbles in this movie yeah yeah
way more butthole somehow yeah well
because they were both male I thought
weren't they no one was female one was
male okay I thought hey well the thing
is is that the female kind of looked
like a male yeah but no they were two
different sexes and then they did have
sex but they didn't show it and then
yeah man Japan got accused of being a
pig he was talking to both of them
because like I said every time he fights
the monster people see it on TV yeah so
then you know if something goes wrong
like when he fought that one monster
that looked like Hellboy you know and he
ran away yeah that was a North Korean
monster yeah then you know that was in
all the papers he liked talking about
what a lame ass is he accidentally
killed the killer killed the baby yes oh
yeah that's tripped over him and killed
him and that Owen other-- funny thing
too I forgot to mention is that every
time one of the monsters dies yeah they
go to have it they go to heaven like
Sarah said like this beam comes down I
go and like their soul comes out of it
it's like the craziest [ __ ] you've ever
seen what else can you tell us about it
but god this just it's funny because the
Wikipedia page it basically just has the
cast and a very short synopsis of the
plot and that's about it okay but it
actually did pretty well I think it um
you know it came out like I said in 2007
it did it towards some festivals and
stuff and um I I feel like I had never
heard of it like when when you showed it
to me
and I feel like even nowadays it's still
kind of under the radar but like I said
shudder just got it recently and they
were super excited about it I got my
email and everything look what we got it
I was like holy [ __ ] I'm so excited we
really wanted to do this but um yeah if
like I said you have to probably have a
particular sense of humor and it's much
funnier if you've seen like other
Japanese monster movies or Japanese TV
shows like so like u-turn ban and stuff
like that because it's satirizing that
and it's also satirizing like reality TV
and you know documentaries in shortage
Japanese culture yeah that divorce and
relationships but in a very like it's
like a very low-key type of way yeah
it's real dead it's real it's very
deadpan real you know yeah which is what
I like about it cuz I'm like that kind
of [ __ ] it's just very very very serious
and I just think that's [ __ ]
hilarious it's like that makes it
funnier to me yeah and you know yeah and
they're like you know what I'm and then
the end of it is just [ __ ] crazy like
even during the credits like him it's
crazier as it goes yeah this just gets
crazier crazier as good as long as the
monsters are just like [ __ ] once they
reveal to you that this is a comedy and
how [ __ ] up it is I'm sure I'm sure
that every every Japanese person when
they would to see this movie knew what
the movie was about yeah it's better if
you don't know it's about because the
more it reveals the weirder yeah the
more absurd the reveals are yeah so it's
constantly one up in itself yeah until
it just gets bizarre towards the end
yeah because like Ludacris yeah because
they're I mean there were several points
the first time I saw this that I'm just
like what the [ __ ] am i watching you
know what I mean but it was like I found
it very entertaining but yeah it'd have
to Ratchet it up as it goes yeah so like
each each monster is like successively
weirder like just weirder [ __ ] keeps and
find out weirder weirder stuff about
about big man yeah man and then it
weirder stuff about his ancestry yeah
and the relationship between him and his
ancestors just you know it's awesome
it's just a super super fun movie but
like I said you know hopefully if you
haven't seen it you're not still here
because right thing right but it's one
of those ones it's much better if you
don't know that much about it because
you can just kind of like let it affect
you or like letter for you you don't
know what's coming because I didn't the
first time I saw it and I real
really liked it very yet but yeah so
money to a blind just really the way to
go yeah so um you know like I kind of
like to do that with all movies but for
especially with ones like this because I
really like to be surprised and you know
it's you know the boards this is just
crazy or crazy or [ __ ] happens and it's
just like super awesome so yeah so if if
you have a shutter they just added it
you can get it on Amazon yeah a couple
weeks ago probably Amazon has it and
stuff like that like I said big man
Japan 2007 so check it out if you
haven't seen it and that will do it for
this latest movie retrospective remember
if you like the show like share
subscribe and all your social media if
you'd like to financially support
showing that our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
remember that our movie retrospectives
just like this one come out every friday
our 13 o'clock matinee show which is
three new movies in the theater comes
out every Sunday and our regular
episodes come out every Tuesday so check
them out and we will see you next time
bye